as christmas looms so does the prospect
of a third wave
with tear changes imminent this week nhs
bosses have urged
extreme caution what they're saying to
the prime minister is
please do not downgrade people into in
their areas into lower tiers
secondly as soon as an area looks like
it needs to
has to go into tier three please put
them in there straight away
and then the third thing we're saying is
look we need a much better debate
about the risks of what's going to
happen over christmas
in a letter to the prime minister nhs
leaders say the significant
extra risk involved with mixing at
christmas is being ignored
and at a time when the health service
will be busiest there are 10 000
fewer beds available than at the same
time last year
one's only got to look at what's
happened in the united states around the
thanksgiving holiday where cases have
surged uh tony factory the american um
chief scientist
advisor on kovit has warned that
christmas could be even worse than
thanksgiving in terms of people moving
around
this is an infection that will
accelerate very rapidly if the brakes
are taken off it's as simple as that
as the government says it won't hesitate
to take necessary action to protect
communities
more rapid test sites are opening up to
track asymptomatic cases
if you want to have that five-day window
you've got to be really careful between
now and then and thereafter
that's why we've got the tiered approach
buttressed by mass community testing
which if you look in
say liverpool you've got the the the
posit the the test
the the um the rate of uh corona advice
down by i think was around two-thirds
three-quarters in fairly short order so
we've got the tools and that does allow
us just to take a little time with our
loved ones
over christmas in germany a national
lockdown's just been announced over
christmas they'll now only be three days
of
minor reprieve for households chancellor
angela merkel blamed christmas shopping
for a rise in cases
action is needed because the measures
that we implemented on november the 2nd
were not sufficient
we were able to stop the exponential
growth in infections for a while
and achieve a stabilization but for some
days now we have been seeing
increasing case numbers and exponential
growth again
this means that we have suffered many
deaths you are all
following the statistics and we know
that the health system is already under
a lot of pressure
there are no calls to change the planned
uk
christmas rules but rising infections
and hospital admissions don't bode well
for a christmas without high risk adele
robinson sky news